[Music]
the Centers for Disease Control will
provide new information today on the
mysterious disease disease known as
acute flaccid mellitus or AFM little is
known about the rare polio light
condition found most often in children
symptoms include sudden arm or leg
weakness and reflex loss the CDC has
confirmed 72 cases in 24 states this
year Adriana Diaz visited eight-year-old
Brandon Noblet who has a FM he received
what doctors say is the first of its
kind surgery that allowed him to walk
again
one Saturday we played baseball
everything was normal
Brian Noblet says his son Brandon's
health deteriorated in just one week in
2016
Tuesday in the Wednesday cold like
symptoms and then as the week progressed
had a headache and neck pain days later
Brandon couldn't use his legs to get out
of bed I knew then something was very
wrong and what did you think your mind
doesn't go to paralysis a doctor
diagnosed Brandon with acute flaccid
myelitis or AFM Brandon now eight years
old was wheelchair-bound what's been the
hardest part for you about this well all
your friends are running around and
playing it's just hard to sit in the bed
and do nothing the whole time the family
eventually turned to dr. Amy Moore of
Washington University in st. Louis my
goal with the children with AFM was to
restore hip stability and then motion of
the upper legs Moore says she's the only
doctor in the u.s. to perform nerve
transfers on children's lower
extremities I used what they had and
they were wiggling their toes and so I
was able to move a nerve that Wiggles
the toes to the hips how are you
14 months ago more performed the nerve
transfer surgery on Brandon at st. Louis
Children's Hospital and relaxed during
last week's checkup
Brandon says he now only uses his
wheelchair to play basketball I wish you
the best
he's doing better now I see you're
walking it's been amazing thanks to miss
dr. Moore I can go outside play on my
brother's play football the cause of AFM
is still unknown
according to the CDC nearly 400 people
have been diagnosed since 2014
in August cases spiked after a 20-17 low
it's a very rare condition about one in
a million during a recent interview for
CBS this morning CDC director Robert
Redfield told John Dickerson he was
calling for a special task force to
investigate AFM it doesn't appear to be
transmissible from human to human we
don't see clustering and Families while
the CDC tries to pinpoint the cause dr.
Moore is working to help those affected
my intention is to give these families
hope that there are options if they get
this horrible diagnosis Brandon says
that horrible diagnosis brought him new
basketball friends and has inspired him
to one day pursue a career in medicine
we don't know where you're gonna go this
is so exciting for CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz st. Louis
yay dr. Moore according to dr. more
children typically respond best to this
type of surgery because their nerves
grow back faster she says nerve
transfers are most successful within
nine months of diagnosis and Brandon
told us he wants to be a surgeon
just like dr. Warren she's onto
something yeah yeah I'll say